welcome back once again to the world of
competitive pokemon we've covered stats
and some of the biggest battle
strategies you need to know so now it's
time to put all that together and
actually make some competitive pokemon
[Music]
you have two options when it comes to
making your own competitive Pokemon you
can breed a perfect one yourself or fix
any old Pokemon up with items
I recommend breeding most of your
Pokemon and saving items for the really
special ones like Chinese and
Legendary's that you can't easily get or
breed again because the items you need
are costly and rare so let's start with
breeding specifically the mechanics of
breeding you need two pokemons to make
an egg obviously they can be a male and
a female of the same species a male and
a female of two compatible species or a
Pokemon of any gender and ditto
you can check whether two Pokemon are
compatible by looking up their egg
groups on a site like therapy Pokemon
can only breed if they share an egg
group there's also some Pokemon that
can't breed it all including the baby
Pokemon and almost every legendary
unless you're using ditto the eggs will
always be the same species as the female
Pokemon so if you only have a male of a
certain species and you want to breed it
you're going to need a deado to at least
start the process you're gonna want a
few things to make this easier The Oval
charm a destiny knot and a never stone
the Oval charm increases the chance of
an egg showing up at the nursery and you
can get it from this guy in the sir
Chester hotel once you've beaten the
game you can buy the Destiny on at the
BP shop in the main hammerlock Pokemon
Center and you can get a never stone
from the digging duo guy on the right
eggs will naturally inherit three IVs at
random from both parents but if you give
one of them a destiny not to hold it the
eggs will get 5 total with only the
sixth being randomized this makes it a
lot easier to pass down perfect IVs
especially if both parents have a few
the Everstone meanwhile actually has two
uses a parrot holding a never stone will
pass down its nature to the offspring
which would otherwise have randomized
natures and it will also pass down its
form if that Pokemon has different
regional variants for example breeding
in a lowland mouth and Galler will
always get you a Glorian mouth unless
you give the lowland mouth and ever
stone on top of that all the alone
mouths you hatch will have to have the
same nature as the parent one luckily
sword and shield introduced the mint
items to let you change a pokemons
nature for the first time so you're not
out of luck eggs can also inherit
certain moves from their parents called
egg moves sometimes their moves at the
Pokemon would learn eventually by
levelling up but a lot of the time the
Pokemon wouldn't be able to learn them
normally and can inherit them from a
parent of another species that knows the
move I use Sara
to check move details like which moves
I'm interested in our egg moves and
which Pokemon can pass them down you can
now get egg moves on your pokémon
without breeding them too which makes
this way simpler I'll talk about that in
a bit
finally eggs mostly inherit their
abilities from the female Pokemon
Pokemon have one to two normal abilities
and many have a hidden ability as well
that you can only get through max raids
or trading unless the female Pokemon has
the species hidden ability you can't get
it just by breeding and you can only
pass the hidden ability down from a male
or genderless Pokemon if you're breeding
with ditto with the normal abilities
most of the eggs will get the female
pokemons but still have the chance of
getting their other ability like with
natures you can change the pokemons
ability any time using the ability
capsule item but it doesn't work for
hidden abilities so you either have to
breed or catch for that if you want it
so quick recap your breeding for Ivy's
nature ability and sometimes moves all
this starts with two Pokemon ideally
they'd have all the right traits between
them and cover each other's wrong traits
so for example if I want to breed a
special attack focused growlithe I might
breed this one with this one
the females perfect special defense IV
makes up for the male's bad one and the
males perfect speed makes up for the
females the female has intimidate which
is the ability I want and the male is
bold which is the nature I want so the
male gets the Everstone and the female
gets the Destiny not they both have egg
moves too including two that growlithe
and arcanine wouldn't normally be able
to learn double edged and Morning Sun if
I wanted to get Morning Sun on a
growlithe from scratch I'd have to get a
male one of these pokemon that knows
morning Sun and then breed it with the
female growlithe first I happen to get
lucky and get this male growlithe via a
surprise trade which can be a really
good way to get starter parents for
breeding a lot of people send out their
breed checks on surprise trade you can
also catch Pokemon with good IVs and
raids and the brilliant Pokemon that you
might see glowing will have a good IV or
two and egg moves the next step is to
put your two parents in the nursery and
start hatching eggs I just kind of do
circles around the nursery area until
the breeder moves her arms which is how
you know she has an egg to make hatching
quicker keep only one Pokemon in your
party and make sure that it either has
the flame body or steam engine ability
these abilities will help eggs hatch
faster you're gonna keep hatching eggs
until you get a Pokemon that's better
than one of the parents you haven't
nursery at which point you can swap them
out so if I hatched a new male growlithe
with perfect IVs and everything but
attack I could swap it for the original
male to increase my chances of getting a
growlithe with the IVs I want you repeat
this process with better and better
Pokemon until you get the perfect one
at which point you're free so what makes
a Pokemon perfect it depends on your
plans if you want it to have its hidden
ability that's a must-have in the
breeding phase and usually you're going
for five perfect IVs with either the
attack or Special Attack stat being the
sixth of randomized one you might also
want zero speed IVs on trick room
pokemon or zero attack IVs on a special
attacker damage from confusion and the
attack foul play is determined by your
pokémon's attack stat and since that
pokemons not going to need its attack
anyway you might as well minimize it if
you're impatient though you can take an
imperfect Pokemon and fix it up in
addition to the mints and ability
capsule I mentioned you can also
artificially max out a pokemons IVs
using hyper training at the battle tower
the Pokemon you want a hyper train needs
to be level 100 and you need to exchange
a bottle cap to do it you can buy all of
these items using BP at the battle tower
one important thing to note though is
that these items don't change your
pokemons DNA so you can't just hyper
train a Pokemon and then use it to breed
for example because it will still pass
down its original IVs mints will change
the way the nature is displayed on the
stat screen but the Pokemon summary page
will still have its old nature so you
can keep track once you've read the
Pokemon the next step is to train it
that includes leveling it up evolving it
and teaching it the right moves but the
very first thing you want to do is Eevee
train it so it doesn't pick up random
EVs as you battle and level it up I
talked about EVs in the first stats
video so if you watch that hopefully
you're ready for the math Pokemon can
have a maximum of 510 EVs across all
their stats with a max of 255 in any one
stat but because four V's equals one
actual stat point the most you actually
want to put in one stat is 252
which then frees up the remaining 6 to
go somewhere else for example I have a
simple Eevee spread on my Togekiss 252
and special attack 252 in speed and for
in defense though it's kind of hard to
tell from this screen the leftover two
V's can go wherever because they don't
actually add anything you'll hear this
kind of spread referred to as full speed
investment or full special attack
investment
you can also do more complex TV spreads
so long as everything is divisible by
four Pro players will often run damage
calculations on sites like Pokemon
showdown to figure out exactly how many
Speed V's a Pokemon would need to be
faster than some other Pokemon or how
many attack V's it would need to one-hit
ko a popular threat you absolutely don't
need to go that hard when Eevee training
though start simple rent some teams and
see what your Pokemon might benefit from
my Togekiss for example could do better
with less special attack investment and
more investment in the defenses to keep
it alive longer like I said in the stats
video Pokemon get v's from battling but
you don't have to battle 250 to
Zigzagoon to get all 252 speed V's on
your Pokemon the vitamin items HP up
protein iron calcium zinc and carbo's
each give 10 V's in their corresponding
stats for that Togekiss I bought 25
calcium and 25 karbas then battled -
oddish for the remaining 2 Special
Attack V's and 2 zigs Ekans for the
remaining 2 speedy DS for the for
defense V's I went and fought for Rolly
Coley's on route 3 therapy has a handy
chart of Pokemon you can battle for V's
and where they're found the vitamins are
expensive though so you can use a few
other methods to Eevee train more
efficiently you can have a Pokemon hold
a power item to increase the number of
EVs it gets in a particular stat by 8 so
if your fighting is eggs egg in your
Pokemon is holding power anklet it will
get 9 total EVs and speed per battle
there's also the rare poker s a virus
your Pokemon can catch that doubles the
EVs it earns from your chosen method to
combine these together really
efficiently you can send Pokemon on the
relevant polka jobs to get them four V's
in one stat per hour which means you'll
get 12 per hour with a power item and 24
per hour with a power item and poke
arrests if you make a mistake while
Eevee training or want to Eevee train a
Pokemon you've already been using you
can feed it one of the Eevee reducing
berries each berry reduces the EVs and
its respective stat by 10 so to fully
reset a pokemons EVs in one stat you'll
need a lot of them there's only a few
trees in the wild area that drop these
berries so don't rely on them too much
once your Pokemon is fully Eevee trained
you can really start to level it up and
make sure it's learning any moves you
want it to know you often want your
Pokemon to have one attack that matches
their
this is called a stab move for the same
type attack bonus which increases the
damage of Pokemon does with those moves
by 50% you then might want coverage
moves or attacks the Pokemon can learn
of other types especially if it'll help
your Pokemon hit opponents its weak to
even on support Pokemon that mostly
needs status and other support moves you
usually want to have one attack in case
your opponent has the move taunt which
forces the target to only use damage
dealing moves for a few turns you can be
pretty flexible with movesets links to
the jack-of-all-trades at every Pokemon
Center who can help your Pokemon
remember any moves that's ever known for
free you can also make your Pokemon
forget a move which is useful for the
egg moves thing I hinted at earlier if
you forgot to breed an egg move on your
Pokemon you don't have to breed a
totally new one like in previous games
instead you can put two Pokemon of the
same species in the nursery for a bit
and the one that knows the egg move will
essentially teach it to the other
Pokemon as long as it has an empty move
slot so let's put all this together if
you watched the first video you might
remember my drag a bolt that was almost
perfect in terms of stats in nature but
had a mess of v's and really bad moves
instead of breeding a brand new one to
be my special attacker I'm gonna fix
this one up step one is getting it to
level 100 it's already at level 97 so
just a few XP candies will do the trick
then I can go to the battles Howard a
hyper train at speed which is the only
perfect IV it's missing I don't need to
drop 50 B P on a mint since it already
has the right nature just by pure luck
and I'm actually gonna leave its ability
as is to infiltrator will allow it to do
good damage against opponents protected
by light screen from a grim snarl and
since it's a special attacker I don't
have to worry about attack drops from
intimidate so clear body isn't as
necessary also I'm gonna give it some
Dynomax candies to max out its Dynomax
level which increases its HP boost when
Diana maxed next I'll fix its moves
luckily there are no egg moves I'm
interested in since it would be more
difficult to transfer egg moves to a
fully evolved Pokemon for now I want
this dragon pulse to be really offensive
so I'm going to replace hex with the
more powerful Shadow Ball for its first
stab attack and then dragon pulse for
its second stab for coverage moves I'll
probably swap between the fire water and
electric options depending on my needs
and for the final move I'll probably go
with protect unless I find I'd rather
have something like thunder wave or Ally
switch because basically all of drak
upholds key moves rTMS or TRS it's
really easy to switch them out on the
fly finally I'm going to reset its v's
using berry
and then give it full speed and special
attack investment with the leftovers in
HP it's a simple spread that fits my
very basic offense oriented plan for
this Drago pole and you can see it's
made a massive difference in its raw
special attack the final touch is
picking an item choice specs is kind of
attractive but you don't want to use
choice items if you have any non
damaging move since you don't want to
get locked into those instead I'll go
with a life orb to make Jack a pole hit
harder while giving it the option to
protect and now he's ready to go and
that's where we have to stop for this
mini series I really hope it helped you
understand more about competitive
Pokemon so you can go out and have fun
battling thank you so much for watching
and as always feel free to reach out in
the comments or on Twitter
[Music]